So here's one way we can define hashtable_add. We're going to define
the procedure hashtable_add. So the first thing we want to do is
find the right bucket. We'll use hashtable_get_bucket we just defined to do
that, passing in the table and the key. We'll store that in
the variable bucket. The next thing we would need to do
is add the new key value pair. And we can do that
using append. Append will add a new element to the list. And
what we want the list to be, is a new list with
two elements, the key and the value. So let's try this in
the Python interpreter, and I've done essentially the same thing that we
did before, except for we don't really need the variable bucket. We
can do the append right away. So i'm getting the bucket and
then append the new entry to it. So we'll start, we'll make
a hash table. We'll keep the size of the hash table very
low. We would never really want a hash table with only three
buckets. But to make it easy to look at the results, we'll keep
the hash table very small, and let's add to our table a key
and value. And for our actual web index the values will be a
list of urls. For our test, they could be anything, so let's just
use a number, and now we can look at table, and let's run that.
And we see we have the table. We have
three buckets, and one of the buckets contains an elements.
If we look at the bucket that we get
from hashtable_get_bucket for the key udacity, we should get the
bucket, that contains the word udacity. let's try that.
That works and we can add some more words to
our hash table, more key value pairs to our
hash table. So now we've, we have got three entries
on our hash table, they all happen to end up in different buckets. That's just
lucky in this case. let's add one more, so we have a bucket that contains more
than one entry. And we should print our table after adding one more.
And now we have one bucket with one word, one bucket with two entries and one
bucket with just one. Now, there is one
big problem, with the way we did hashtable_add.
Suppose we add the same word again, and let's say
now the value of udacity is 27. So now we
are making a hashtable that has three buckets. We're adding
a bunch of entries to it, we've added the entry udacity
twice, now when we get the bucket for udacity. What
we see is we have a bucket that has the
same keyword twice. If we want our hash table to
be a mapping between keys and values, this is going to be
a problem. If we have the same keyword twice, when we
look up udacity, well, we don't know which answer we should get.
Is the value 23 or is the value 27? So, what we
want is something a little different from add. What we want is
to make sure that every time we add a new keyword
to the hash table. If it already exists, instead of having two
entries with the same keyword. What we'll do is change the value
associated that is associated with that keyword. So we have a problem
if we have two entries with the same keyword. We're
going to fix that later. Before we fix that, let's define
look up. And it will turn out that lookup will
actually be helpful in defining a better version of add.